where everything's better with a little
curly some things you think you're gonna
be trying today I feel like it would be
something that wouldn't have to be
refrigerated probably eating some sort
of like plankton tasty sustainable stuff
[Music]
it just looks like I knew it was mail
right away so I guess that's a good
thing vegan vegan Mayo does that mean
all future foods are vegan does that
mean all vegans are from the future
oh I'm flipping this upside down is it
going straight on the tongue it's great
I would buy this look I'm not the
biggest Mayo guy but that's from the
future I'm gonna tell myself this is a
chicken nugget cause it looks like a
chicken nugget
this is this is science food well they
look like ghosts in motion is it
plant-based I'll find out you could
totally trick kids and tell them these
are chicken nuggets and they'd believe
you house cardboard ground-up deep-fried
biggest roommate but who cares if it's
actually checking them it's better for
you and you can like trick your brain
trick the brain
oh god it's gonna be Soylent that easily
it looks like Android blood from the
Alien franchise ha ha oh my god this is
like what an alien would make if they've
never seen food it's like somebody
crumpled up a bunch of wheat added water
and said here you go
nutrients nothing bad just nothing good
and what's very willing when there's
only Soylent
[Music]
oh no their pancakes this looks like
some kind of meat pancake I have maple
syrup in my car in case of pancake
emergencies
they probably have like cricket butts in
them really its cricket flour
nailed it mm-hmm oh god it's just so
like gritty like that is a tasty future
right there I love it
[Music]
it's got like a weird sweet smell to it
hope you've made out of like old
starbursts can I come oh it's so hard
I'm gonna throw up it would be fun for
kids this should just make a whole line
of kitchen utensils if I had to drink
silent I want to drink it out of this
they were all kind of a little bit weird
I like the idea of the Soylent best just
it just makes sense and I feel like it's
something I've tried to see if it would
be beneficial to my health future food
dig it so I think we just need more like
people going through fields and eating
plants and seeing which one stays like
mayonnaise or cheeseburgers be careful
lots of plants are toxic it's just so
sad what's happening over there oh yeah
you don't know the half of it
[Music]